hello and welcome to mat simplified
in this video we are going to talk about
how you can detoxify your lungs
and keep them healthy our lungs are one
of the most important organs of our body
performing the vital function of
delivering oxygen to our blood
which is a lifeline of every cell in our
body however
lungs are among the organs which are
constantly exposed to the outside
environment
and its pollutants breathing in air
pollution
cigarette smoke and other toxins can
damage the lungs and even cause serious
health conditions
the cigarette smoke settles on the
bronchial tubes and air sacs
causing a decrease in breathing capacity
and inhaled carbon monoxide disrupts the
body's oxygenation
to give you an estimate of the burden of
disease cigarette smoking is responsible
for more than 480
000 deaths per year in the united states
alone
including more than 41 000 deaths
resulting from second-hand smoke
exposure
this is about 1 in 5 deaths annually or
1300 deaths per day
according to the world health
organization exposure to air pollution
results in 4.2 million deaths worldwide
each year
now lung detoxification techniques can
benefit people who smoke
people who get regular exposure to air
pollution and those with chronic
conditions that affect the respiratory
system
diseases like asthma chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease or cystic fibrosis
so in this video we will be talking
about how you can protect your lungs
from further damage
and methods you could use to detoxify
your lungs
then we will look at some of the foods
and supplements you can include in your
diet
to keep your lungs healthy so without
further ado
let's get started with the number one
thing that we have in our list
which is to protect your lungs from any
further damage
while you can't entirely undo years of
damage from sacred smoking
the best thing you can do to detox is to
protect your lungs from any further
damage
the most important thing smokers can do
in this regard is to obviously stop
smoking altogether
now i know for most of the smokers it
can be an impossible task
but you can always try there are plenty
of resources available on the internet
for smoking the addiction
and i will leave all the relevant links
in the description bar down below
nevertheless if you're not planning on
quitting anytime soon
what you can do is reduce your frequency
of smoking
that is very important for non-smokers
it is also very important to avoid
secondhand smoke
while quitting smoking is the most
important thing you can do for your
lungs
it's crucial not to breathe in other
people's smoke as well
use face masks in places where there is
high level of air pollution
the air passages in our lungs have
microscopic finger like projections on
them
known as celia the celia and sticky
mucus
work together to protect the lungs from
infection
the mucus traps any bacteria or
pathogens as they enter the lungs
and the celia move in a synchronized
pattern to move the mucus
up into the airway back into our throat
where it can be swallowed
and any pathogens can be killed by the
acidity of the stomach
if we are smoking constantly or we are
getting exposed to high levels of air
pollution
the cilia in our lungs do not function
properly and they are unable to clear
our lungs from various particles in the
smoke
as well as bacteria and other pathogens
so if you want to detoxify our lungs and
implement the other methods
we are going to talk about next in this
video it is very important first that we
reduce our exposure to smoke
and other forms of pollution this allows
our celia to function properly
and help in the recovery of lungs in a
much better way
number second thing to do is to control
your indoor air pollution
indoor air quality also contributes to
lung diseases
dust irritants and chemicals can build
up in your home
people with lung diseases usually spend
a lot of time indoors
and it's important to do so on days when
outdoor air quality is poor
here are few suggestions to help improve
the indoor air quality
clean up vacuum oftenly and invest in a
good quality vacuum cleaner
mop your floors but try not to use
chemical laden cleaners
dehumidify your rooms dust and mold
grow very quickly in a humid environment
use a dehumidifier or keep your exhaust
fan running while cooking
to prevent the growth of mould test for
radon gas
radon is a radioactive gas occurring
naturally in the ground
and it contributes to lung cancer it can
get in your home from the foundation
pick up a radon test kit at any home
improvement store
go chemical free use natural cleaning
products
fragrance free products and avoid
aerosol sprays
purify the air inside your home indoor
plants such as
fern spider or aloe vera can help purify
air you can also use an air purifier
i have included links to some of the
best air purifiers that automatically
sense the air quality
and remove 99.97 airborne pollutants
as small as 0.003 microns
so these were the first two things in
our list cutting down or completely
avoiding smoking
and avoiding outdoor air pollution and
cutting down the levels of indoor air
pollution
now let's talk about the ways you can
detox your lungs
these include postural drainage proper
diet and exercise
let's talk about them one by one so
number one thing is postural drainage
postural drainage is the drainage of
lung secretions
using gravity in postural drainage the
patient's body is positioned so that the
trachea
is inclined downwards frames tilt tables
and pillows may be used to support
patients in these positions
here are some techniques to perform
personal drainage
number one position is done by lying on
your back
lie down on the floor or a bed place
pillows under the hips to ensure that
the chest is lower than the hips
then slowly inhale through your nose and
exhale through your mouth
each exhale should be taken twice as
long as the inhale
which is called one to two breathing
this should be continued for a few
minutes
the number second position will be
performed by lying on your side
lie on one side resting the head on an
arm or a pillow
place pillows under the hip and practice
the one to two breathing pattern
continue for a few minutes and then
repeat on the other side
the third position will be done by lying
on your stomach
place a stack of pillows on the floor
and lie down with a stomach over the
pillows
remember to keep the hips above the
chest
fold the arms under the head for support
practice one to two breathing pattern
and continue for a few minutes postural
drainage relies on the effect of gravity
to drain the secretions from one
or more lung segments into the central
airways
where it can be removed by huffing or
light cuffing techniques
each position is usually held for 10
minutes and these should be done for
four to five days per week
do these positions in the morning to
clear mucus that's been built up
overnight
or right before bed to prevent coughing
during the night
avoid doing postural drainage after the
meals
so this was about postural drainage the
next important thing that you can do to
detox your lungs is
exercise just like regular exercise
makes your muscles stronger
it also makes your lungs and heart
stronger
now exercises for lungs can be divided
into two types
the first one is your regular cardio and
aerobic exercises
which include jogging cycling swimming
or any sport that pumps up your heart
choose what suits you the best and
perform at least 30 to 40 minutes of
these exercises
five times per week cardio and aerobic
exercises are very good for lung health
because when you perform these exercises
the blood flow in your pulmonary vessels
increases many folds this helps to heal
the damaged tissue of our lungs
and helps in the overall process of lung
detoxification
the second type of exercises you can do
for better lung health are breathing
exercises
breathing exercises help to improve the
lung function and lung capacity as well
especially for individuals who are
smokers who have smoked in the past
or who have lung damage from a chronic
lung disease now there are many types of
breathing exercises
for example diaphragmatic breathing
burst lip breathing etc
i will leave links to some of these
videos in the description box down below
that will explain the procedure of how
you perform these exercises
so this was about the exercises you
should do to help to recover your lungs
to a healthy state
now let's talk about some of the things
you should include in your diet for lung
detox
number one is green tea green tea
contains many antioxidants that help to
reduce
inflammation in the lungs these
compounds may even protect the lung
tissue from the harmful effects of smoke
inhalation
a recent study involving more than one
thousand adults in korea
reported that people who drank at least
two cups of green tea per day
had better lung function than those who
drank none
you can also include vitamin d in your
diet a vitamin d
rich diet also improves your lung health
the best
food sources of vitamin d are usually
animal products such as salmon
sardines eggs milk butter etc
make sure to give 10 to 20 minutes of
exposure to sunlight per day
so that the vitamin in your body could
be converted into its active form
you should also include antioxidant
foods in your diet
nutrient dense foods especially those
abundant in antioxidants are well known
for helping the lungs
recover to their optimal health
antioxidant rich diet helps to
neutralize the free radicals
that damage the lung cells thus it is
very important to consume foods that are
packed with antioxidants to promote
overall lung health
some of these foods include apples which
contain a variety of phytochemicals
including quercetin catechin fluorescein
and chlorogenic acid
all of which are strong antioxidants red
bell peppers also contain
abundant antioxidants vitamin c and
carotenoids
turmeric and its powerful ingredient
curcumin have powerful antioxidant
health benefits
as well blueberries are believed to have
one of the highest antioxidant levels
of all common fruits and vegetables the
main antioxidant compounds in
blueberries are known as
flavonoids some other very good foods
that have
abundant antioxidants include green
leafy vegetables
lentils beans grapes walnuts and garlic
so these were some of the foods that you
should include in your diet
that will help in your lung detox
process you can also consider taking
antioxidant supplementation
i have included links to some of the
best antioxidants i have found in the
description box down below
i hope you liked the video if you did
support us by hitting the like button
below
and you can also support med simplified
by clicking the join button below or
joining us
on patreon page all links are in the
description box down below
thank you so much for watching this
video see you in the next one